Heat.
[Music] [Applause] [Music]
Heat. Heat. Heat. [Music]
[Applause] [Music] [Applause]
[Music]
Hello and welcome to another episode of What's Up
Prof. Hi Walter. Hi Martin. I see we're smiling
at least. I don't know if it's a good one. I
don't know. Is there anything to smile about
in this world? Sure. Well, yeah. Know it's not
very wasn't a very happy week or few weeks that
gone past in the world. So, we've titled it the
storm is coming. Relentless in its fury. And I
see the man has a more of a rifle scope than a
telescope in his hand. Yeah. So there's been a
lot of discussion about the events of the last
few days and week. So uh perhaps we should try
and make some prophetic sense out of all of this.
That's it. Because otherwise we can be sucked
up into one of the avenues again. All right,
let's pray. Let's pray. Our heavenly father,
we are thankful that we can be here. We ask your
blessing and your help with the Holy Spirit to
guide us in Jesus' name. Amen. Amen. Martin, I
have a feeling that we need the wisdom of Solomon
in order to navigate these waters. Yeah. Because
if you say just the wrong thing, you either have
the left or the right down your throat. Yeah. You
can even be fired. You can lose your job. You can
get into all kinds of of turmoils. And so I
think we should put a disclaimer there right
from the beginning. We are not here to unpack
or discuss uh the motives of people. We are not
here to discuss their uh ideologies other than how
they fit into a prophetic profile. We are not here
to uh climb into characters of people and we're
definitely not here to make political choices. No,
we've all from the first episode we've made
that clear. No, we don't choose sides. We don't
choose sides. We look at the consequences and
what the ripple effect in the future will be.
And uh I think people by now will know that we'll
probably talk about the Charlie Kirk issue. Yeah.
And there have been so many uh documentaries and
discussions and uh theories and conspiracies and
this and that and the other. Some blaming the
left, some blaming the right, some blaming other
entities. And nobody seems to be sure and nobody
seems to be happy with the official narrative. And
those that that bring the official narrative, they
stick with it. I don't know. It's the same that we
did with the Trump assassination attempt. Exactly.
We don't we don't took charge. We just look at
what the consequences will be. Where's it heading?
All right. So let's have a a brief look at what
some of the people are saying and what uh what the
implications are of all of these thunderous events
that are taking place. And maybe we can also just
add that we are opposed vehemly opposed to any
life being taken at any time. Oh yes, we do not
propagate any form of violence and uh if people
want to push it in that direction then it is a
very sad reflection on society. uh views should
be able to be expressed and uh let's not go in any
direction that will cause any discontent in regard
to that issue then okay one thing that we have
to bear in mind Martin is that we've had a lot
of discussions of king of the north versus king of
the south philosophy now uh it It's true that you
cannot dump an entire King of the South philosophy
into one party's vision. So that's not what we are
doing. We're not denigrating one party and saying
that it entirely reflects either the king of the
south or the king of the north philosophy, but
there are elements within these ideologies that
reflect those philosophies. So for example, the
Democratic Party, which is the party of the left,
will have many of the king of the south
attributes within its framework. Of course,
not all of it. And many on the Republican side
will have the king of the north aspects. Yeah.
And these aspects that are involved will come into
a clash situation. Mhm. And we are told that the
philosophy of the king of the north where the
religious aspects will be legislated in order
to legislate morality will overrun the other
philosophies. That is what the scriptures say.
But the overrunning will be done in terms of
a philosophy that is not necessarily biblical
but based on the morality of man and certain
religious institutions that have deviated from
the word of God. Yeah, that's about it, right?
So let's have a look at the rhetoric how they're
trying to push this into a leftright issue. Yeah.
So the aftermath of what happened now because of
the assassination is really pushing this narrative
in that direction. Yeah. Yes. Hatred and political
violence are dramatically becoming a reality
again, bringing many unresolved issues to the
surface. He would simply sit in public and allow
anyone to challenge him in a debate on any topic.
I say this also because in recent days I have
read many inhumane comments about the death
of Charlie Kirk and I have read others that were
truly frightening. An intellectual from the left
who said shooting Martin Luther King and shooting
a MAGA representative are not the same thing. Does
it mean that we should imagine lighter sentences
for those who shoot a right-wing figure? Perhaps
considering as a mitigating factor the fact that
their ideas are unacceptable. Look, I believe it's
time to hold the Italian left accountable for
this constant downplaying or even this ongoing
justification of the criminalization and violence
against those who don't think like them because
the atmosphere even here in Italy is becoming
unbearable. Britain's patriots, my friends,
today I call upon all of you to invoke the help
of your country's patron saint, St. George.
Legend holds that St. George fought against
a dragon that was demanding human sacrifice.
He fought a battle of good versus evil. And today,
hundreds of years later, we are
still fighting that very same fight.
We are fighting a fight of truth versus lies,
of freedom versus tyranny, and of light versus
dark. And just three days ago, one of our
bravest warriors lost his life fighting it.
So today, we also fight for him. We fight
for Charlie Kirk. We fight for our nations.
We fight for our children. Today is not
the time to just keep calm and carry on.
Today is the time to get angry,
demand change, and fight back.
Watch as European politicians refuse to observe
a minute silence for Charlie Kirk. Swedish MEP
Charlie Weames had dedicated the rest of his
allotted speaking time to a silence in memory
of the Turning Point founder. Please stand with
me in reflection and prayer in his honor. And
I yield the rest of my time for a moment of
silence. But parliamentarians had other ideas.
MEPs were outraged.
MEPs were pointing out the parliament had
observed a silence in memory of George Floyd
after he was killed in 2020. The scenes
echo the ranker scene in the US Congress
on Wednesday night where some Democrats were
accused of refusing to pray for Charlie Kirk.
The chair would ask that all members present in
the chamber and those in the gallery please rise
for a moment of prayer for Charlie Kirk
and his family. Let's let's let's wait
a minute. Wait a minute. The house will
be in order. The house will be in order.
The house will be in order.
We [Music] The house will be in order.
So Martin, without choosing any sides, I think we
can clearly say that the collision has now become
public. Oh, that's sure. You know that we always
said uh uh the heelian dialectic to rub each other
up against each other to get a thin synthesis. We
can clearly see that this is getting to a point.
All right. Now, the question is, will it all die
down and go back to business as usual or will
this escalate into the final conflict? If we read
Daniel 11, then it seems to me that the momentum
of the king of the north will increase until he
overruns the entire opposing uh narrative. Right.
And therefore the religious political which was
really embodied in Charlie Kirk will according
to scripture gain ascendancy. Mhm. So there
is an escatological aspect to this. Would you
agree? Well definitely. I can can't see how you
can um sever the two. All right. Now it doesn't
necessarily have to be Charlie Kirk. It can be
anything. The fact of the matter is the scriptures
will say that it's going to happen. So we don't
have to talk about the motives or the character
or whatever. We're looking at the result of what
what has happened. And the interesting thing is
that according to Revelation chapter 13, the
movement of taking control of the situation and
giving power unto the first beast which is Rome.
In other words, Rome and Catholicism must be very
central to this issue. Right? Yeah. That'll start
from the United States of America. And according
to that it will flow over into the rest of the
world with the United States giving the lead.
Right? Is it happening in the United States? Well,
just this event or the well tragedy has got that
going that the whole world is following and it
has rippled across the nations where this divide
of left and right seems to be very prevalent at
the moment. Yeah. Yeah. So now we're going to
just briefly have a summary from another YouTube
program just putting these things into perspective
and seeing where we are. The memory of Charlie
Kirk is starting a revolution all across America.
But I had no idea he'd have such an impact in
the UK all the way down to marches in Australia
and back up to movements in South Korea where
ironically this reminds me of those recent riots
in France 4 days ago where the far-left burned a
Korean restaurant in protests of French leadership
as these concurrent protests just highlight the
key differences between the left and the right
as reportedly this Tik Tok was about Charlie. The
best part of this whole thing is that he is not
martyr material. So his death will mean nothing.
It will activate no one. It will impact few.
It's just great. completely oblivious
to the vigils hitting college campuses
with huge crowds even in New York City
as NASCAR races paid their respects,
but also MLB games as a New York Yankees had
a moment of silence alongside the NFL also
honoring his life. But then we started seeing
Spain paying their respects. Arches all the
way in Australia holding up signs for Charlie with
South Korean citizens singing we or Charlie Kirk.
[Music]
where we all knew the assassination of Charlie
Kirk was going to ignite American conservatives
and moderates but nobody could have imagined he
would become the face of freedom for the entire
planet as at the UK's Unite the Kingdom march
which was reported as 110,000 people but was more
likely millions. This is the counter revolution.
There's been a globalist revolution for 20 years.
We are the counter revolution. It's not going
anywhere, mate. Carrying posters of not only
Charlie Kirk, but his entire family as they all
rallied behind his memory. To Charlie's family,
we all pray for you and we hope we honor his
life. Marching through the streets of London,
one of the largest right-wing demonstrations to
take place in the UK in modern times. organized
by the far-right anti-immigration activist Tommy
Robinson. Close by a much smaller counterprotest
organized by anti-racism activists. I'm just
ready against racism. So close at one point that
right-wing marchers began throwing things at them
and pushing police. So, as the calls for political
violence have only amplified, people are now
losing their jobs in neurology at universities.
Microsoft is combing through their ranks to do
the same. And even American Airlines is firing
pilots who think it's okay to celebrate murder
as we're seeing a turning point not only in the
US with Americans making it their mission to dish
out consequences, but now conservatives worldwide
are rallying behind Charlie as a left didn't even
think he'd be seen as a mortar. But now Charlie's
known globally as the face of finally fighting
back. So I think we can s safely say that this is
now universal. That's for sure. And an interesting
thing that I've picked up also and you probably as
well the religion is not served from this. No,
it's a political religious movement. It comes as
a package. And there are a couple of things about
the religious aspect that we will have to unpack.
and uh Martin that march that took place in
England where they said there were a 100,000. Now
I know what a 100,000 people looks like. That's
a that's a big stadium full of people but that
was tens of stadiums full of people because that
queue and that crowd went on forever. So I think
uh millions is probably better with a counter
movement that nearly came to blows simultaneously.
Yes. And smaller. So it shows you also which one
has the ascendancy. Now the one that the one that
is aligned with king of the north philosophy has
the ascendancy. Well, Obama says the US faces
political crisis after the killing of Charlie
Kirk. Former US President Barack Obama has
warned of a political crisis of the sort that we
haven't seen before in the wake of the killing of
Charlie Kirk. The attorney general, Pam Bondi, has
suggested that the administration will crack down
on hate speech. Although there's no specific US
hate speech law, Vice President JD Vance has led
calls to expose people who celebrated or condoned
Kirk's killing or were critical of him after his
slang. And as we heard people from United Airlines
that spoke against it, they were asked to set step
aside. People from Delta, I heard people from
the military, people from any form of government,
employment, teachers, university staff, anybody
who spoke anything negative, stood a chance or did
actually lose their jobs. That just shows you. I
mean, and also what Pam Bondi mentioned that they
want to crack down on hate speech, there was a big
flare up on that. She actually went back and and
apologized from what I've heard because there is
no hate speech laws and who is to determine the
hate speech. You remember this is a big thing.
That's a big thing. Who's going to determine
it? But we are moving into a situation where any
form of counter argument irrespective of what that
argument is will not be tolerated. and modern
that is reminiscent of what is described in the
scripture. You will not be able to buy or sell.
Martin, if you lose your job, sooner or later you
won't be able to buy or sell because you'll run
out of money. Yeah, that's exact. You know what?
But it's exactly like was it Tommy Robinson the
guy that was organizing that thing said for 20
years or whatever the other side was pushing
and remember the whole time we were talking
about when Biden was in power they had similar
rules or things for people that had anything to
say against transgender or the whole woke issue
all that issue. So this is almost like payback.
So Martin was this king of the south philosophy
pushing the king of the north philosophy worldwide
not only the and then the consequence will be that
the king of the north will come with all the power
at his disposal. Uh does that include the national
guard? Yes. In other words, military power,
economic power, were there sanctions against
people that voiced the different philosophy
and that he will overrun it. Yeah. And now it has
escalated to this. All right. The incident is sad,
but it is prophetic. Yeah. in Texas 100 plus
teachers to lose certification over the Kirk
posts. So the Texas Republican Governor Abbott
and the Texas education agency have announced that
more than 100 educators are under investigation
and could face suspension of their teaching
certifications. But not only teachers, lawyers,
uh many of them and broadcasters have been removed
and programs have been removed. This is in fact a
form of censorship. Definitely. We're not arguing
for it or against it. We're just taking notes of
what is happening. Right. If that if so this is
a sad situation where this has happened. Yes.
But what if it's a more political situation in
the future and then they still crack down on it.
Correct. So the the implications are enormous.
Yeah. Or or even religious because then we are
right where the Bible says we'll be where we
said. So is there a storm coming? Martin prophecy
in its fury. Could this burst into anarchy and
violence? Yeah. And like our previous one said, be
careful that we're not caught with an overwhelming
surprise because the storm is coming. Yes. Let's
watch what uh President Trump had to say. For far
too long, Americans have been forced to put up
with Democratun cities that set loose savage,
bloodthirsty criminals to prey on innocent
people. Really, very, very innocent people.
In every place, they control radical left
judges, politicians, and activists. And
they've adopted a policy of catch and release for
thugs and killers. In Charlotte, North Carolina,
we saw the results of these policies when a
23-year-old woman who came here from Ukraine met
her bloody end on a public train. And it's time to
stop this madness. The people of our country need
to insist on protection, safety, law, and order.
We have proven that it can be done because we did
it right here in DC in District of Columbia, the
capital of America. Was a bloodthirsty, horrible,
dangerous place, one of the worst. And now it's
a crime-free city. And we're going to keep it
that way. It can be done. It can happen fast. All
we want is please, Mr. President, we need help.
Chicago needs help. Other cities needs help. We'll
do what has to be done because we're going to make
America safe again. In the wake of Mr. Kirk's
murder, Donald Trump had called for a calming
impolitical rhetoric. It's long past time for all
Americans and the media to confront the fact that
violence and murder are the tragic consequence of
demonizing those with whom you disagree day after
day, year after year, in the most hateful
and despicable way possible. For years,
those on the radical left have compared wonderful
Americans like Charlie to Nazis and the world's
worst mass murderers and criminals. This kind
of rhetoric is directly responsible for the
terrorism that we're seeing in our country today.
I'm not the youngest guy on the on this earth and
I remember uh American politics way back. not
only American politics but British politics,
uh, Western politics in general. And there was
always this bantering between the various parties,
the left and the right. But the difference was
not so great that it should lead to violence and
there was always a generally peaceful transition
of power from one form of government to the other.
the, you know, the liberal aspects were always
there or the conservative ones, they called
themselves conservative and and more liberal, of
course. But this divide has just become greater
and greater and greater and it seems as though the
left has become radicalized, but the right is also
radicalized from a different aspect. Yeah, for
sure. Now, Martin, who's steering that behind the
scenes? That obviously there has to be somebody.
There is. And we know who it is. We know who's
steering this behind the scenes. And this tendency
to give uh exposure to the ideologies that you
want to create to create the divide. Who's who's
behind that kind of thing also? And did not even
religious bodies play a role in this? Mhm. Didn't
religious bodies, whether in Catholicism or in
Protestantism, choose sides and either go the
ultriberal woke way. Yeah. Or the other way.
Yeah. So also they also had a divide. Yes. And
in the last few election times that we've had,
it seems as if the left had the ascendancy.
And if a right proponent voiced his concerns,
then he was pushed aside. Let's take the Catholic
um archbishop or bishop Vigaro. Vigo Vigano. how
how he was excommunicated for going against, you
know, the more woke agenda of of Pope Francis,
etc. And you had the conservative bishops and
you had the the others and now there's sort of a
little bit of a swing, right? And the conservative
voices are becoming stronger. Yeah. So, you had
this push and now you have this anti- push. And
the financial moguls, are they involved in this?
Oh yeah. All over. Doesn't the Bible talk about
the merchants of the world and the rich people
and how they are associated with Babylon? Yeah.
And are they also pushing certain narratives?
Now in the past you always heard about the left
narrative, right? And the multi-billionaires that
were funding uh left-wing riots and immigration
and this and that. And these multi-billionaires
were either demonized or hero worshiped and now
you're seeing the trend from the other side more
and more. So let's hear what Elon Musk had to
say. Yeah. Just before we did you think or did
you mentioned now earlier politics was there
ever a time that you think that more than 50%
of the people would have said no violence is okay
with somebody that you don't disagree with. No,
it was all there was violence but it was never
condoned by anyone. And I find it interesting that
the older generation today in the United States is
around about the 80 plus% against violence. That's
it. But generation Z or zed as it is in English,
they are over 50% in favor of this kind of
violence or condone this kind of violence. That's
what I what I'm trying to So here is a whole
generation that has been raised to either stick to
one philosophy even if it takes force to do so or
the other philosophy. So do we have a recipe for a
anarchy and a clash? I think definitely like never
before. So let's hear what Elon Musk had to say.
And then you see how much violence there's on the
left uh with our our friend Charlie Cook getting
murdered in cold blood this week and people on
the left celebrating it openly. The left is
the party of murder and celebrating murder.
I mean, let let that sink in for a minute.
That's who we're dealing with here. That is
who we're dealing with. Elon, to so many of
the British public who are scared to exercise
their free speech. They're worried about being
imprisoned. They're worried about being attacked
even to share their speech on your platform of X.
What message would you give to them? This is this
is a message to the reasonable center. The people
who ordinarily wouldn't get involved in politics
uh who just want to live their lives. They don't
want that. They they they're quiet. They just go
about their business. My message is to them if
this continues. That violence is going to come
to you. You will have no choice. This is a this
is you're you're in a fundamental situation here.
Whether you where whether you choose violence or
not, violence is coming to you. You either fight
back or you die. You either fight back or you
die. And that's the truth. Today, Elon, I think
we're I think the British public are telling the
world that they're ready to fight back. I think
the many British people had lost hope. But after
today's scene, have you got hope again? Britain,
Britain is awake. Thanks to you, Elon. Thanks
to your input. Can we just ask Thanks to you,
Tommy. Thank you, brother. Can we ask
what what do you see as the future of
the UK Europe in your vision? What's where are
we heading? What's the future like for us? Well,
I I I think I I think there needs to be a future
where there is where where people take charge,
where there's there's deregulation, uh a massive
reduction in bureaucracy, um and generally a new
hope, uh where people look forward wake up in the
morning, they look forward to the future. They're
excited about what's going to happen next. Um
and um but we we must have uh revolutionary
government change for that to occur. And this
this is not ordinary course of business sort
of stuff. Um this really requires everyone to to
sort of marshall the people um so to take charge,
reform the government, um and make sure that you
actually have a government that is for the people
by the people. Nobody did it better. You spelled
out two of Charlie's goals. He said, you know,
he wanted to bring people back to Christ and bring
people back to church and back to biblical values.
And he wanted to keep the mega coalition together
and expand it and expand it. And the question is
how you do that. And the answer is you focus on
the first and the second is a byproduct. Okay.
The answer is that as Matt says, you have to unite
around something. And yeah, we can unite in the
short term around the fact that there are a bunch
of people who hate our guns and want to murder us.
uh which of course is true, but long-term unity,
big movement change, which is what Charlie was
really trying to drive and why he went to talk
to people who disagree, is about building around
those core values. And so the long-term vision,
yeah, we'll have our petty squables and yeah,
some of those squables will be more than petty,
but the long-term vision has to be built around
those original biblical conservative values
that Charlie stood for. Things like the Bible,
things like free markets, things like family,
you know, all those things are things Charlie
stood for. You got to build the coalition around
values because we can't build it around the man,
but we can build it around the values that he
left behind and that he spent his entire life
fighting for. And you know, we couldn't be
frankly more honored to to join you guys as
much as we can in the fight. So, Martin, are we
now really tying the religious to the political?
This is the like one guy said, a watershed moment.
It's amazing how this joint religious and this
revolution movement is grasping hands. Didn't he
call his organization Turning Point? Yeah, this is
prophetic. In fact, this is sensational. Didn't
Musk say uh we need a revolution? Basically,
that's it. And you fight back. You either fight
or die. Yes. He basically in that whole speech
riled up and said, "You better take the government
back. You have to take your country back. You have
to take your country back." So it's basically the
same slogan as the Trump movement slogan. Yeah.
Repackaged for the other countries. That's it.
And we're going to see this happening in England.
We're going to see it happening in Europe. We've
saw it in Italy. It's going to happen in Germany.
And who knows what's going to happen in France.
They're very good at revolutions. So maybe their
enthusiasm is flowing over into another kind of
French revolution. Doesn't prophecy also say that
will happen? Isn't it amazing how the media has
linked the offensive or to the right offensive
doctrines of the left to the violence? Yeah.
So that for example transgenderism now becomes
the murderer. Yeah. Whether that is so or whether
that is not. So that is what the media portrays.
The right leaning media. Yes. The left media is
so has got a totally different narrative. But
you can still see that they pushing that this is
going to be a clash. So when they sweep it away,
they not only sweep away a structure, they sweep
away an ideology as well. Yeah. And it's important
again, although people have probably seen it many
times, just to reiterate that this movement is not
going to stop here, it's going to escalate.
Let's listen to what his wife had to say.
The evildoers responsible for my husband's
assassination have no idea what they have done.
They killed Charlie because he preached a message
of patriotism, faith, and of God's merciful love.
But they should all know this. If you thought
that my husband's mission was powerful before,
you have no idea. You have no idea what you just
have unleashed across this entire country. In this
world, you have no idea. You have no idea the
fire that you have ignited within this wife.
The cries of this widow will echo around
the world like a battle cry. Charlie,
I promise I will never let your legacy die, baby.
I won't. I I promise I'll make Turning Point USA
the biggest thing that this nation has ever seen.
Now we have to be very careful when we go into the
conspiracy narrative. Yeah. But there are some
very very prominent people that are projecting a
kind of conspiracy narrative. Uh we think about
Candace Owen for example who has brought out a
very lengthy uh program about this issue and she
seriously questions some of the narratives out
there. And some of these people that are going
to be seen now in the next little clip that we
have are people that are associated with the
world court. And we know that uh certain people
have been indicted by the world court, Benjamin
Netanyahu, even the present pope and the previous
one and many political figures and that there is
a sort of um drama around this issue with Donald
Trump condemning some of these these indictments
and all of these things. But these are just things
that are happening behind the scenes. So it's very
interesting to hear what this Kevin Annet had to
say on the issue and he's one that is pretty much
linked to what is going on in this world court
situation. Let's hear what he has to say. The
information I'm going to share tonight is coming
from the court itself. And one of the 13 people
who were accused and who were subpoenaed actually
has come forward and has provided information that
led to what we're going to talk about today. So
it's coming from them just to clarify that. And a
subpoena was sent out to all of them last Monday.
So that's September 8th. Two days later, less than
two days after that, Charlie Kirk gets killed.
The next morning, right after that, the court
received uh a communication from one of the 13.
They're not saying who it was. So, these are one
of the people who received the summones to appear
next Monday the 15th before the court. And as
they've been accused with of participating in
these ninth circle sacrificial cults, you know,
all over the world and other associated crimes,
this person who came forward and they haven't
identified who it is for their own safety, but
this person has sought to make a deal. In other
words, he wants immunity from prosecution and
he'll name other people. Some of the information
that this witness who's come forward, one of the
the accused has provided this information. He
claims that uh over the last number of weeks
there have been meetings between what's called
Santa Alanza that that's called the Holy Alliance
in Latin. That's the Vatican assassination and
spy bureau. And they've been meeting with their
counterparts in the Mormon church. Now don't
forget Charlie Kirch was killed in Utah at a
Mormon University, Oram, Utah, and he was killed
by a Mormon student. Now, this counterpart to the
um Santielanza, the Vatican Assassination Bureau,
it's they're called the Danites, D- A N I T- Ess,
and they're an assassination group that goes back
into the right to the period in the 19th century
when the Mormons were first formed. when they
moved out west, they they basically said that
anyone who wasn't a Mormon, uh they called them
Gentiles, they were accused of blood atonement,
that is, you have to sacrifice your own blood to
pay for the sin of not being a Mormon. And these
Danites basically go around and and kill people.
And there's been a whole history of that. Even
the Mormon leadership has admitted that they
operate. Now, I interviewed a whole number
of Mormon survivors and they described that it
was the Dayites who were trafficking children,
taking them to these rituals and you know where
they were murdered and everything. So, they are
it's a proven agency. Now, this eyewitness says
that the the Dayites and the uh Santi Alansza
were planning a hit on someone, right? And what's
interesting about uh Charlie Kirk is that he had
knowledge of a lot of this stuff. We know he was
like Trump's era parent. They were they got along
a lot and Trump is a kind of guy who shares a lot.
He doesn't keep a closed mouth. And there was more
evidence coming that Charlie Kirk knew that and
might have been exploiting that. That at least was
in the minds of the Vatican. There they want to
clean up uh what's the term I used? They want to
uh house clean. They want to make sure there
aren't any loose ends because they can't have
Trump and these other guys found guilty and face,
you know, arrest warrants because this is huge
geopolitically. We're talking the head of NATO.
We're talking the president of the United States
and the Pope. These guys, they can't upset the
apple cart that way. So, they got to remove any
witness, anyone who potentially is uncertain. Now
Martin, not that we want to run in this channel
that these people are proposing there, but in
Candace Owen's program, she also questioned the
narrative as to whether it was even possible that
uh the shooter acted alone. just the assembly of
the rifle, the deasssembly of the rifle, the
reassembly of the rifle, the wrapping it up,
how to get it there, how to do all of that in the
space of time that was available. Uh she is asking
questions as to whether the official narrative
actually is correct or not. That is not what we
want to talk about. In the clip that we just saw,
uh, they impliced the sanct aliance, which is the
Jesuit secret service. If you look it up in the
in the web pages of the world today and Google,
they'll say, "Well, that was started, you know,
during the Reformation period in order to set up
a a secret police that could investigate things
or partake in things like assassinations and that
uh it's, you know, it's a it's a hypothetical
theory whether they still exist or don't exist.
The fact of the matter is if something works
for the Vatican, normally they keep it going,
right? Mhm. And they might change the names.
They might change the name of the Inquisition to,
you know, the congregation of doctrine and
faith, but it's the same thing in the same
building with the same agenda, the overthrow
of Protestantism. Now, as far as the overthrow
of Protestantism is concerned, Martin, I
think they've done a pretty good job. Oh,
yeah. What we have today is not Protestantism.
Not anymore. Nobody's protesting. In fact, they've
publicly acclaimed that they agree on some of the
doctrines now and that Protestantism is dead. So,
what we have is another religion. Yeah. It's a
it's a religion that is based on Catholicism with
Protestant flavors without an antichrist that is
ruling at the moment but someone that will come
in the future. Mhm. and moving in a direction
that is supposedly spiritdriven but totally
contrary to what the scripture says it should be
to the law and to the testimony. If they speak
not according to this word there is no light in
them. So modern whether there were ideological
problems that were surfacing whether there were
divides or not is irrelevant. What is the outcome
going to be? Mhm. Now we read in Maronata the
following. Then shall that wicked be revealed,
whom the Lord shall consume with the spirit of
his mouth, and shall destroy with the brightness
of his coming, even him whose coming is after
the working of Satan with all power and signs
and lying wonders. And this is a reference to the
the man of sin. Yeah. This is a reference to what
the Protestants claimed was the papal power. And
he would come with this mighty power but in the
end he will be destroyed. But revelation tells
us that the second beast Protestant United States
will give power unto the first beast. So they will
give this power and with lies and power plays and
so-called holy spirit events they will overrun the
ideological thinking of the world. So they'll be
doing all of these things in the name of God but
it's actually doing the bidding of the first beast
of the first beast. So Paul in his second letter
to the Thessalonians points to the special working
of Satan in spiritualism as an event to take place
immediately before the second advent of Christ. So
there must be a tremendous increase in spiritism.
Now spiritism comes in many forms and spiritism
has supernatural occurrences. So spiritualism and
spiritism, spiritism is the movement. Mhm. Where
spiritualism is the manifestation if you can put
it that way. uh comes in many forms and it can be
manifested in many religious movements as well
and we've spoken about that and many of those
movements that are contrary to the law of God
or negate the law of God but claim the presence
of the spirit cannot be from God because
the two have to be linked together. Right?
So we have spiritualistic movements within
Protestant movements in the world today and these
of course rile up the emotions under the so-called
working of the Holy Spirit when that spirit leads
you away from obedience to God's precepts. Yeah.
And that's false. Yes. Now Martin, this will lead
to revivals. But there will be false revivals.
Saman, can we expect false revivals just before
the coming of Christ? For sure. And some events
like this can hurry it on. All right. So, let's
have a look at revivals all over the world and
see whether the the scenario fits. But eventually,
there must come a true revival. Yeah. Mhm. And
the spurious must be separated from the real.
Right? So let's have a look at revivals around the
world. Something very weird is happening in the
world right now. Revival for Jesus Christ
is breaking out in Germany, New Zealand,
Italy,
London, Korea, Brazil. It's happening all over the
world right now. This just happened in Australia.
Christ is king. quiet and in London, Pakistan,
Venice, Poland, Sweden, Paris, France, half a
million in Poland, the Netherlands, Mexico, and
yes, my own country, United States, from Boston,
Denver, Washington DC, Hollywood, even San
Francisco, even the White House. American Idol
streamed a three-hour worship session. This is the
turning point. Revival is happening. We've been
praying for one last revival before Antichrist and
darkness reigns. This is the turning point. If you
agree, type amen and subscribe to make Christians
stronger. Martin, this is a turning point. Yeah.
Like like I said, so this assassination
or can be they link it to this revival.
So when this revival links with the political
aspirations, don't we then have a recipe for
Revelation 13? Mhm. All right. So here's another
quote. Spiritualism asserts that men are unfallen
demigods, that each mind will judge itself,
that true knowledge places men above all law,
that all sins committed are innocent, for whatever
is is right, and God does not condemn. Do we have
that philosophy in virtually every denomination?
Yes. Martin, do you think it is pure chance that I
said every denomination on this earth? No. That's
why I said yes. I see. So you mean we must face
this kind of philosophy as well. We were warned by
the spirit of prophecy that spiritualism will be
one of the probably the omega. Okay. So the basis
of human beings is rep it represents as in heaven
and highly exalted there. Thus it declares to
all men, it matters not what you do. Live as you
please. Heaven is your home. Multitudes are thus
led to believe that desire is the highest law,
that license is liberty, and that man is
accountable only to himself. With such teaching
given at the very outset of life when impulse is
strongest and the demand for self-restraint and
purity is most urgent. Where are the safeguards of
virtue? What is to prevent the world from becoming
a second Sodom? Martin has the world ventured onto
the road of becoming a second Sodom. Yes, I think
it's already there. So, isn't that a good reason
to bring in a morality? Oh, for sure. Now what if
that morality is not biblical? What then? Yeah.
Then we've got prophecy unfolding. All right.
So while this is happening, at the same time,
anarchy is seeking to sweep away all law. Not
only divine but human. Do we see that? Yes. Okay.
The centralizing of wealth and power. Do we have
that? Definitely. I mean, who has ever earned a
trillion dollars? Yeah. As a salary. As a salary.
Can you imagine earning a trillion dollars? That's
more than most states have, right? I think it's
more most countries can be blown. That's what I'm
saying. More most countries. The vast combination
for enriching the few at the expense of the
many. Do we have that? Mhm. The combination
of the poorer classes for the defense of their
interests and claims. The spirit of unrest. Do
we have that riot and bloodshed? The worldwide
dissemination of the same teaching that led to the
French Revolution. All are tending to involve the
whole world in a struggle similar to that which
convulsed France. Are we on the precipice? We are
there because it's every country and we'll look at
a few ones now. It's everywhere. All right. So, is
there a storm coming? Relentless in its fury. Now,
what if you go back in history? Mhm. How many wars
started with an assassination? Oh, probably most.
All right. Now, how do you change an assassination
into a revolution or a war? Even if it is an
ideological war, you can't do it without the
media. Yeah. Propaganda. Propaganda. Right.
And then you have a movement and then you sweep up
the emotions. Now if you add the religious element
then that sweeping up of the emotions would that
be from God or from another spirit? Unfortunately
another spirit but it will seem so real and for
the people that are involved with it. That's why
it's so important to have your minds clear because
you can get sucked up into this. I mean we saw
this with this whole thing the assassination of
Charlie. Yes. how quickly you got people on this
side and this side and they just want to fight
each other. Now they asked over there what Elon
Musk ask that the the old system in Britain should
be swept away basically it should be overrun.
Yeah. Right now let's have a look what happened
in some other places like Nepal for example.
Nepal finds new calm this weekend with the
appointment of a temporary leader following
an extraordinary week of violence. The death
toll now stands at over 70 after anti-corruption
protests led to police clashes and a host of
buildings in the capital being set a flame. An
interim prime minister is in place today asking
for people to come together. New elections are
expected to be held in March, but key issues like
unemployment and inflation that drove the protests
remain unressed. Yeah, it's becoming clearer
and clearer, Lisa, that the social media ban,
which was the approximate cause or the trigger
for the protests. It was a small part of a great
big angry hole. It was Monday of this past week
that the mostly young people took to the streets
in great numbers. And you could see already on
the banners and placards they were carrying,
it's much more about entrenched problems that
uh Nepal faces, political problems, corruption,
a culture of impunity and there was a vast amount
of anger and and then that all changed on Monday
itself when armed police started firing into the
crowds very quickly. A lot of young people died
uh by police bullets and then there's an entirely
new cause for outrage. So Martin the unrest can
be purely political but if you add a religious
element then it becomes ideological. Yeah. So
Nepal, Bangladesh, Sri Lanka is South Asia fertile
for the generation Z revolution. The building and
its plush interiors had been symbols of crushing
authority, impenetrable and out of reach for the
country's teeming millions. Now, however, they
briefly belong to the people. So, these kinds
of things are happening everywhere. So Nepal is
a country of 30 million people sandwiched between
India and China and now plots its future in ways
alien to traditional electoral democracies. The
spate of youthled protest movements that have
toppled governments one after the other in
South Asia has also sparked a broader question.
is the world's most densely populated region
ground zero for generation Z revolutions. They're
talking about the same things if you look on the
internet about China. Yeah. Brewing unrest from
the young generation. But where was this whole
thing that happened now in the US taking place
at the university? Young people. Who was the
shooter? The alleged shooter. They're all young
people. young. It's this generation. Correct. So,
was this generation groomed for this Martin?
For sure. And who are the expert groomers? Now,
when you go back in history, when when
you have a movement that starts like this,
you start with the young people always. You always
have a youth movement attached to it. And the
Freemasons understand that very well. That's why
they have the demol and weren't even presidents of
the United States involved in the demise. So this
grooming takes place at a particular level and we
can always feed it right back. What was that
um episode or lecture that you had because the
catcher and the rye that book is also it that's
what it's about correct to for the to to rile up
the young people against authority. Yes. And to
show the the inconsistencies and the poverty and
to use all of these measures to get what we want.
So we read in the great controversy before the
final visitation of God's judgments upon the earth
there will be amongst the people of the Lord such
a revival of primitive godliness as has not been
witnessed since apostolic times. So Martin God's
people will have a revival. So even if there are
people caught up in these false revivals but they
are there because of the knowledge that they have
when the true revival come they will many come out
correct but there must be this primitive godliness
correct pushing it now the spirit and power of God
will be poured out upon his children at that time
many will separate themselves from those churches
in which the love of this world has supplanted
love for God and his word. Many both of ministers
and people will gladly accept those great truths
which God has caused to be proclaimed at this
time to prepare a people for the Lord's second
coming. The enemy of souls desires to hinder this
work. And before the time of such a movement
shall come, he will endeavor to prevent it by
introducing a counterfeit. Yeah. In those churches
which he can bring under his deceptive power,
he will make it appear that God's special blessing
is poured out. There will be manifest what is
thought to be great religious interest. Multitudes
will exalt that God is working marvelously for
them when the work is that of another spirit.
Under religious gu Satan will seek to extend
his influence over the Christian world. Are we
seeing it? It's actually phenomenal to see this
happening before our eyes now. It's very sad that
situations like the Charlie Kirk situation can be
used as a vehicle to introduce something like
this because what you need for a false revival
is emotions out of control. Ah, that's what you
need because it's emotiondriven as well. Correct.
While men will not heed repeated warnings, they
are pleased with false teachers who flatter their
vanity and strengthen their iniquity, but who will
fail to help them in the day of trouble. We've had
so many false preachers, prosperity gospels, uh
everything is about money and nothing is about
obedience with the most blasphemous statements by
some of these preachers. We don't even have to go
there. And their churches are packed. What are
they feeding on? Emotion. What about the There
was this whole narrative going out now that
the rapture will be now the 23rd. I think on
the 23rd we'll have a rapture. Well, I'm afraid
Martin, if I know my prophecy, I'm sure you will
agree it'll turn into a rapture and not a rapture.
Yeah. their thoughts will be ruptured. I'm sure.
But how much they they also part of this whole
false movement. Yes, there's a massive false
movement going on right now. So God's chosen
servants should meet with courage and patience
whatever trials and sufferings befall them through
reproach, neglect or misrepresentations because
they faithfully discharged the duty that God has
given them to do. They should remember that the
prophets of old and the savior of the world also
endured abuse and persecution for the word's sake.
They must expect to meet just such opposition as
was manifested by the burning of the role that
was written by the dictation of God. This is a ref
uh reference to Jeremiah's scroll that he dictated
to Baruk. Yeah. The Lord is fitting a people for
heaven. the defects of character, the stubborn
will, the selfish idolatry, the indulgence of
faultfinding, hatred and contention provoke
the wroth of God and must be put away from his
commandmentkeeping people. Martin, we cannot climb
onto barricades. No, don't get sucked in. We can't
join any of these emotional rallies or whatever.
And we must be careful not as you said to be
sucked in to this philosophy. You know emotion
is such a strong force that you could see how
in every video that people were so emotional
that's where it starts emotional crying sad and
then anger. Yes. Those living in these sins are
deceived and blinded by the ws of Satan. They
think that they are in the light when they are
gropering in darkness. There are murmurers amongst
us now. And even as they were murmurers amongst
ancient Israel, those who by unwise sympathy
encourage men in rebellion when their self-love
is smarting beneath merited reproof are not
the friends of God. The great reprover. God
will send reproof and warning to his people as
long as they continue upon the earth. I've read
things from our own ranks. That smack of political
intrigue, Martin, we cannot be involved in that.
We must do introspection at this stage and look
at what's coming upon the earth. Now, Martin,
what we're going to talk about now should not
be misunderstood. We're not talking about the
sincerity of what people believe or whether
they had hidden agendas or whether they didn't
have hidden agendas, whether they were involved in
particular movements or not involved in particular
movements. I am sure that God has millions out
there who have light on certain issues but not
necessarily light on other issues. So we are
not there to judge someone if he presents light
but according to our understanding doesn't have
light on other issues. Let God be the judge of
that. What are the issues that will come out yes
of what just happened? What were the sentiments
of Charlie Kirk? What did he believe? What can be
made prominent and what can be twisted? Yes. Isn't
that important? It is. You remember Ben Shapiro
when said there, how can we let Charlie's legacy
continue? He brought in the religious. So,
let's see what the events will lead to. Well,
here's a a tweet by him where he said, "We talk
about a golden age in America. I'm an evangelical
Christian, but I pray the new pope will help
usher in a new golden age of Christianity." Well,
he was married to a Roman Catholic girl. If the
new pope defends the faith, defends the West,
defends biology and eternal truths, I will be his
biggest fan. So obviously there was sort of an
ecumenical mindset here. Yes, he he wasn't opposed
to anybody as long as they did what was right. All
right. So let's go back to the book of evangelism
and read the following. In the great closing work,
we shall meet with perplexities that we know not
how to deal with. But let us not forget that the
three great powers of heaven are working. That
a divine hand is on the wheel and that God will
bring his purposes to pass. So what is written in
the book of revelation and in the book of Daniel
will happen and we can look at the triggers that
can lead in that direction. Yeah. Is it in the
book Ezekiel that he saw the great wheels? Yes.
It looks like chaos, but the hand of God is under
it and controlling it. Every position of truth
taken by our people will bear the criticism of
the greatest minds. The highest of the world's
great men will be brought in contact with truth
and therefore every position we take should be
critically examined and tested by scripture.
Now we seem to be unnoticed, but this will not
always be. movements are at work to bring us to
the front. And if our theories of truth can be
picked to pieces by historians or the world's
greatest men, it will be done. Now, we've just had
the opportunity, and we spoke about it in the last
two programs to speak with some of these people
that have great influence religiously speaking
and politically speaking. So, it is coming to
the front. What'll bring it more to the front?
So Charlie Kirk was very passionate about the
Sabbath. Now it's not absolutely clear that he
sees the Sabbath like we would see it for example
but it was very important for him for the family
for example and that is also a position that the
papacy has their Sabbath which is Sunday should
be made prominent for the sake of the family.
Now, Charlie Kirk was in favor of the seventh
day Sabbath, but was he dogmatic about it? That
we cannot tell. But he recognized that the seventh
day was the Sabbath. So whether he was for an
ecumenical mindset or not is irrelevant. Is the
Sabbath going to become prominent? Yes, like we've
just seen, it is coming and it be God will have
it put in the right place and then people have to
make a decision. They have to make a decision. So,
we've had a couple of discussions now with
prominent people where the Sabbath was an
issue. Let's hear what Charlie Kirk had to say on
this issue. The the Sabbath is one of my favorite
topics to talk about, honestly, cuz I'm so sick
of talking about politics all day long. It's all I
do. So, it's it drives me crazy. This is actually
way more important than that. And I could tie the
two together if necessary, but we don't have to.
Uh, however, I grew up in a church environment
that at the very best would deemphasize the
Shabbat, at the very worst say that the Sabbath
doesn't really matter. The Sabbath is in your
heart. You don't need to observe it. Yeah. And
the the story is quite long. I'm actually writing
my next book on the Sabbath. It's called Stop in
the Name of God. Uh because Shabbat means stop
or ceasing. So, I'm not here to sell you a book.
It's not even for sale yet. It's just something to
think about. And it's honestly how the the Sabbath
saved my life and helped preserve my family
and helped preserve my career. I also go to
churches across the country. I speak at hundreds
of churches of all different denominations. And
I will challenge the Christian church cuz I
believe this is the most ignored commandment
of the decalogue to our own detriment. And I will
go a step further and then I'll stop talking cuz
I know we have a whole program. No, it's fine. uh
which is that I believe that honoring the Sabbath
is the commandment that allows you to honor the
other nine commandments and that the enemy has
gone after the honoring the Sabbath because then
it is easier to weaken the other nine. You know,
I think Charlie um was definitely on the brink
of changing some of his perspectives and um I
can tell you factually Charlie was praying the
rosary. Charlie was going to mass. One of my last
conversations with Charlie was me joking with him
saying, "Just make the last step." Okay, you are
uh I said specifically, "You're too smart to be a
Protestant. Just take the last step, Charlie." He
says, "Haha, you're speaking about uh Mary." And
typically when those steps start taking place,
you stop referring to yourself as I did as a
Judeo-Christian. One of my major major concerns of
Catholicism. And I mean, look, I love Catholics.
You know, as people know, I'm very close to even
my local Catholic priest, Father Klein, great guy.
My wife was baptized Catholic, but I have some big
disagreements with Catholicism. And the first of
which would be marology. But let me first say I
think we as Protestants and Ev evangelicals under
venerate Mary. She was very important. She was a
vessel for our Lord and Savior. I think that we as
evangelicals and Protestants, we've overcorrected.
We don't talk about Mary enough. We don't venerate
her enough. Mary was clearly important to early
Christians. I have three major theological
disagreements uh with Catholicism. It's not
a mystery. I talk about it publicly. The first of
which would be the infallibility of the pope and
the whole process and the idea of the Vatican. The
second of which is marology. The third of which
which is just less, you know, less important, but
it's transubstantiation. Um, I I I do not hold
that view. Martin, can we sum up from what we've
just heard that the Sabbath is going to be an
issue? That's the basically from what the uh quote
that we read before we watched the videos. Yes,
that it will become prominent. From what Candace
Owen said, he was leaning towards Catholicism. She
encouraged him to take the final step because
how can an intelligent person not be Catholic,
right? That's what she basically said. I would
beg to differ of course on that issue, but uh
let's leave it at that. Well, he was praying the
rosary according to her and uh that's repetitive
prayer which is actually also forbidden in the
Bible. And then he has his three points where
he disagrees with Catholicism. So I'm not going
to argue about whether he had this ideology or
that ideology. He was basically experimenting and
thinking about all of these issues. Then his book
Martin stop in the name of God. Right. Yeah. which
is now a best seller and number one on Amazon even
though it's not even published yet. Yeah. And it
deals with the Sabbath. Can that be swayed into
an argument for a Sabbath rather than the Sabbath?
Some people can probably twist it. He you know to
say a Sabbath. All right. Can we say that because
he defends also the seventh day Sabbath that the
issue of a first day Sabbath and the seventh day
Sabbath can become a prominent issue for the last
days? Yeah. Well, definitely it's going Bible
says it will. Don't they want to celebrate his
legacy? Yeah. So, Martin, historically, doesn't
that happen in the time of a storm? Yeah. So,
is a storm coming? And like we've discussed
with Douglas Wilson, the majority will choose
the other. All right. And the difference between
Catholicism and Protestantism, is that becoming
obvious? Oh, yes. Hasn't Protestantism rejected
that idea that there is a difference? Yes,
they have. They've said, you know, it doesn't
make any difference. It's not a problem anymore.
Now he also stated that uh you know it's not a
really big issue transsubstantiation. It was a
big issue in in the reformation and there were
martyrs that went to the stake rather than to
acknowledge transsubstantiation. Right. Yeah.
Well the thing is the main thing why we showed
that video is to show that the Sabbath through
this event is really and with his book coming out.
Look at where the Sabbath is now. How prominent.
Just like the quote we read. All right. So the
people that defend the seventh day Sabbath, will
they automatically also become prominent? Yes,
you have to. So will they come to the front
in terms of this debate? Yeah. All right. Now,
who are those people? Isn't it largely the
seventh day Adventist denomination? Yes,
them and then obviously the Jews. But the seventh
the Adventists stand for the Christian version.
Okay. Now what's interesting to me Martin is that
according to the Talmud a Christian in other words
a non Jew may not keep the Sabbath. That is in
the same way that a Jew keeps the Sabbath. That
is very interesting. In fact, it even says in the
Talmud, although people will argue that these are
the opinions of rabbis, it even says in the
Talmud that a non-Jew that keeps the Sabbath
like the Jews keep the Sabbath should be killed.
Wow. Is not worthy of living. That's fascinating.
So Martin even if you have a scenario where a
different uh religious system like the Jews in
in Israel for example where they keep the Sabbath
they claim that their laws can be enforced their
religious laws when they have a temple. Uhhuh.
Isn't there a movement to reconstruct the temple?
Yeah. A big one. And didn't the vice president of
the United States just visit the very spot where
they claim where this temple is in one of the
tunnels underneath and this excitement to build
the temple. So Martin, even if that nation were
to keep its Sabbath and not change to Sunday, if
you were a Christian keeping the Sabbath such as
in the same way that they keep it, when they can
implement those laws, should they become religious
laws, they would persecute the Christians that
keep the Sabbath like they keep it. Yeah. But
not those that don't keep it like they keep it.
They won't be they won't be persecuted. So either
way, whether you visit Israel or whether you stay
in a Christian western country, if you keep the
Sabbath in the way in which a 7th day Adventist
would keep the Sabbath from sunset to sunset,
Friday evening to Saturday evening, then you
would be in trouble. Yeah. You would be persecuted
on both ends. Yeah. So, one the the New York Sun
says to celebrate the legacy of Charlie Kirk who
put a premium on faith, honor the Sabbath. Now,
Martin, if that is the case, then they must
keep the seventh day Sabbath because that's
the Sabbath. If they want to honor a papal
Sabbath, then they must keep Sunday. Right?
So, the conservative activist leaves behind
a nearly completed book about the day of rest
and worship, a biblical concept he championed
in his personal life. He was murdered one day
after the foundation for individual rights and
expression released a discomforting survey showing
that onethird of university students believe
violence is an appropriate response to speech.
There are two easy ways we can all honor Charlie's
legacy. At the time of his death, Charlie was
putting the finishing touches on a book about
the Sabbath. Yet another biblical concept he
championed in his personal life. It would be
a fitting tribute to Charlie and the Hebrew
Bible rooted form of Christianity that he like
the American founders so greatly championed for
more Christians and Jews alike to honor Charlie by
committing to honor the Sabbath just like he did.
So Martin, the Jews could honor it like the Jews
and the Christians could honor it like the Pope
prescribed and said he changed it from the first
day from the seventh to the first day of the
week. And the Christian that keeps the Sabbath
like prescribed in the Bible, in other words,
like the Jews keep it today, would be in trouble
whether he was involved with the Jews or whether
he was involved with the Christians. Isn't
that interesting? Very interesting. So,
it shows it actually gives you a precursor of
where we're heading with this. Is it the point of
contention? Yeah. Now, people said it would never
be a point of contention, but Martin, here it is,
a point of contention. CBS News, Paramos sues
American Dream for staying open Sunday in
violation of Bergen County blue laws. Modern. This
is modern America. Yeah, this is right now. Yeah,
it was few weeks ago. Okay. So, the New
Jersey Bureau of Paramos is suing the
American Dream Mall for staying open on Sunday
in violation of Bergen County Blue Laws. Now,
they're arguing this way or the other. Whether
they apply or whether they don't apply, it doesn't
really matter. The fact of the matter is there
is this agitation. Yeah. It's enforcing. So there
are blue laws that are still being enforced and
they didn't adhere to that. Yes, obviously this
will just start getting more same is happening in
Europe. So modern let's look at this statement and
the great controversy and see whether this is now
not only possible but probable. The Sabbath will
be the great test of loyalty, for it is the point
of truth especially controverted. When the final
test shall be brought to bear upon men, then the
line of distinction will be drawn between those
who serve God and those who serve him not.
While the observance of the false Sabbath,
that's Sunday, in compliance with the law of
the state, contrary to the fourth commandment,
will be in a vowel of allegiance to a power
that is in opposition to God. The keeping of
the true Sabbath in obedience to God's law is an
evidence of loyalty to the creator. Interesting,
right? Mhm. Well, one class by accepting the sign
of submission to earthly powers receives the mark
of the beast because Rome has said it is the mark
of their power that they've changed the Sabbath
from the seventh to the first day of the week.
The other choosing the token of allegiance to
divine authority receive the seal of God. Here
to fall, those who presented the truths of the
third angel's message have often been regarded as
mere alarmists. Their predictions that religious
intolerance would gain control in the United
States, that church and state would unite to
persecute those who keep the commandments of God,
have been pronounced groundless and absurd. It has
been confidently declared that this land could
never become other than what it has been, the
defender of religious freedom. But as the question
of enforcing Sunday observance is widely agitated,
the event so long doubted and disbelieved is
seemed to being approaching and the third message
will produce an effect which it could not have
had before. Martin, who are we to say that only we
should speak about the Sabbath? Can't the stones
cry out as well? And they are. Isn't that what hap
what's happening here? How how much did we or any
of our denomination had to do to get the Sabbath
up there? Well, this has made it more prominent
than anything else. So, if our denomination is
snoring and not willing to, you know, go onto the
battlefield with this issue. Well, then others
might make it prominent so that you are forced
to wake up. Yeah. So make the distinguishing
mark prominent. We are to give the world a
manifestation of the pure, noble, holy principles
that are to distinguish the people of God from
the world. Instead of the people of God becoming
less and less definitively distinguished from
those who do not keep the seventh day Sabbath,
they are to make the observance of the Sabbath so
prominent that the world cannot fail to recognize
them as seventh day Adventists. Would you agree
with that statement? I 100% agree with it. You
see, it it's actually quite sad that a nonseth day
Adventist makes the Sabbath so prominent. I'm I'm
actually stunned that it has happened this way.
Uh, and maybe it can be an incentive for God's
people to finally stop snoring and start preaching
the message, especially if you have some authority
or are up in a high place like in government for
instance. Absolutely. A distinct people with a
testing message. The Lord has been pleased to
give his people the third angel's message as a
testing message to bear to the world. John beholds
a people distinct and separate from the world who
refuse to worship the beast or his image who
bear God's sign keeping holy his Sabbath, the
seventh day to be kept holy as a memorial of the
living God, the creator of heaven and earth. Of
them the apostle writes, "Here are they that keep
the commandments of God and the faith of Jesus."
This is the issue. This is what is happening in
the world. We are seeing the false revivals. We
will see the prominence of the Sabbath versus a
Sabbath. And whether the Jesuits were behind it,
whoever was involved is irrelevant. What is the
final outcome of the issue? So with these plain
words before us, who of those who know the
truth will dare to make less prominent the
distinguishing features of our faith? It is an
established fact to be made prominent before
all nations, kindred, tongues, and peoples,
that the Lord God made the world in six days,
and rested on the seventh day. Thus the heavens
and the earth were finished, and all the host of
them. And the seventh day God ended his work which
he had made and he rested on the seventh day from
all his work which he had made. That is the bottom
line. You either believe God or you don't. You
either do what he says or you don't. The choice
is theirs. Let's pray. Amen. Heavenly Father,
we are stunned how the principles written in
this word of yours are coming to the four.
How the issues that we have spoken about for so
long are being made prominent by whatever means.
And the final conflict will revolve around this
issue. And I pray that people will make correct
choices based on the word and thus says the Lord.
That is our prayer in Jesus' name. Amen. Amen.
Heat. Heat.
[Music]